[Musique]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 14 avril des
négociations nucléaires avec l'iran
ainsi que la situation en ukraine au
menu donne une visioconférence de l'otan
le dombass qui entraîne des tensions
diplomatiques entre la russie d'un côté
l'alliance atlantique est des états unis
de l'autre le kremlin se dit prêt à
étudier la proposition de sommet
formulée hier par joe biden le retrait
des troupes d'afghanistan également au
menu de ce sommet de l'otan joe biden le
prévoit d'ici au 11 septembre
un report de quatre mois par rapport à
l'accord conclu en 2020 la russie estime
que son retard risque de provoquer une
escalade washington revenant de son
accord passé avec les talibans
le cobp il gabriela talent promet un
hommage aux victimes alors que le triste
cap symbolique des cent mille morts va
bientôt être franchie en france quant
aux mesures pour les voyages avec les
pays les plus touchés elles devraient
être durcies et présenté lundi
emmanuel macron présidera demain une
réunion pour aborder la sortie crise
alors que la réouverture du pays promise
à la mi mai interroge moscou affirme que
le spoutnik v ne cause pas de trompes au
de thrombose le vexin russe pré commandé
par le président de la région provence
alpes côte d'azur renaud muselier en
attendant la validation de l'agencé
européenne du médicament prévue pour fin
juin
johnson and johnson lui va bien être
administré comme prévu aux plus de 55
ans en france malgré la pause aux états
unis après des cas de caillots sanguins
le danemark me relance définitivement
astrazeneca
[Musique]
le crès nos coeurs dont des tensions
géopolitiques entre la russie l'otan et
les états unis alors que kiev accuse
moscou de grandes manoeuvres à sa
frontière la russie annonce des
exercices militaires en mer noire une
poussée de tension qui n'améliore pas
les relations entre washington et moscou
mais le dialogue n'est pas rompu pour
autant joe biden propose à vladimir
poutine de poursuivre leurs échanges
lors d'une rencontre dans les prochains
mois françois xavier lambert les avions
et les navires militaires russes se
déploie en direction de la mer noire en
organisant ces exercices de grande
ampleur moscou concrétise ces annonces
face aux activités de l'otan qu'ils
jugent menaçante une réaction jugée
proportionnée par le ministre russe de
la défense
en réaction aux activités militaires
menaçante de l'alliance atlantique nous
avons pris les mesures appropriées en
trois semaines deux armées trois
divisions de troupes aéroportées ont pu
être transférés vers les frontières
occidentale de la russie pour participer
à ces manoeuvres russe coïncide avec la
visite du secrétaire à la défense
américain à bruxelles à l'occasion d'une
consultation menée par l'otan alors que
l'ukraine et la russie s'accusant
mutuellement de masser des soldats leurs
frontières respectives
washington annonce l'envoi de 500
militaires supplémentaires en allemagne
une décision qui satisfait le chef de la
diplomatie ukrainienne
ce dernier a sollicité l'aide du
secrétaire général de l'otan jens
stoltenberg ukraine et nos amis restent
vigilants nous ne perdons pas et nous ne
perdrons pas de temps et si moscou
devait prendre des mesure imprudente ou
entamer nouvelle spirale de violence
cela coûterait cher dans tous les sens
du terme
je tiens à vous rassurer l'ukraine ne
veut pas la guerre nous ne prévoyons pas
d'offensive ou d' escalade
le crem se repose sur les moyens
diplomatiques et politiques pour régler
ce conflit
les tensions entre occidentaux et russes
sont directement liés à la reprise des
combats ces dernières semaines dans le
dos
région de l'est de l'ukraine où l'armée
gouvernementale combat des séparatistes
depuis 2014 alors que des pourparlers
doivent reprendre prochainement entre
kiev paris berlin et moscou
le processus politique est toujours figé
c'est dans ce contexte que joe biden et
vladimir poutine se sont entretenus au
téléphone le président américain a
proposé à son homologue russe
d'organiser une rencontre dans les
prochains mois afin de bâtir une
relation stable avec la russie selon les
mots de la maison blanche
d'après le kremlin les deux dirigeants
se sont dits prêts à poursuivre le
dialogue pour garantir la sécurité
mondiale l'ukraine au coeur des tensions
géopolitiques entre la russie l'otan et
les états unis place à notre décryptage
avec nos invités pour en parler avec
nous claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales karim b
checcolo fco professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être là pour ce
décryptage sur la situation en ukraine
et ses conséquences avant de vous faire
réagir je voudrais vous faire écouter le
commentaire de jens stoltenberg
secrétaire général de l'otan lors de la
réunion de la commission otan ukraine
c'était aujourd'hui à bruxelles
nous discuterons également des actions
agressives de la russie en ukraine
nous sommes tous préoccupés par ce
renforcement terre massif à la frontière
et la russie doit y mettre fin
elle doit cesser les provocations et
procéder à une désescalade détention
karina bisch ecoval go une réaction à
ces propos à 7 ce point de vue de
jens stoltenberg le premier que j'ai pas
été connectées donc j'ai pas pu entendre
ce qui s'est passé en substance le
secrétaire général de l'otan qui dit
voilà on est préoccupé par ce
renforcement militaire massif à la
frontière avec la russie qui doit cesser
ses provocations et procéder à une
désescalade immédiate
bonjour donc effectivement ou peut être
un peu surpris de ce genre de propos
puisque ces derniers temps les les
américains renforcent leur présence
militaire sous couvert de l'otan dans le
en ukraine
et rappelons quand même que les troupes
russes elle se trouve sur le territoire
de la russie
donc s'ils disent calade il doit y avoir
peut-être faute
ils demandent aussi un retrait au thé
kenyan des des troupes étrangères qui se
passe sur place certes il y a
actuellement des exercices militaires
qui sont prévues
nice n'est pas ils raisonnent ou pour
provoquer un site et puisque comme l'a
souligné d'ailleurs là aussi ils ont les
informations selon lesquelles l'otan
vers 1,2 d'activités de soutien et de
formation à la craie nien met en place
des bases pour lancer derrière des
coupes qui peuvent lancer les attaques
terroristes notamment en russie n'est
pas une également s'inquiéter pour de
petites la turquie dans tout ce
processus effectivement il ya un
problème si vous voulez très très
sérieux puisque c'est une zone
extrêmement sensible et lorsqu'il y à un
conflit territorial avec une dominante
militaire comme c'est le cas en ukraine
avec le dombass il est quand même
surprenant de voir des exercices de
l'otan se passer sur ce territoire
en tout cas c'est ce que dit moscou qui
dénonce un déploiement massif de troupes
à la frontière comme l'indiquent le
ministre russe de là
défense que l'on écoute en réaction aux
activités militaires beau naissance de
l'alliance atlantique nous avons pris
les mesures appropriées en trois
semaines les armes et trois divisions de
troupes aéroportées ont pu être
transférés vers les frontières
occidentale de la russie pour participer
à des colloques maison c'est un petit
peu compliqué l'ancien diplomate que
vous êtes en tout le monde se renvoie un
peu la balle dans cette affaire alors
c'est vrai que la russie fait que tu des
exercices militaires comme nous l'a dit
karine béchu goal of qu'auprès des
frontière ukrainienne mais l'otan et les
états unis pourtant loin de chez eux se
rapprochent dangereusement la frontière
de la russie c'est une différence qu'il
faut relever tout de même je crois que
depuis depuis sept ans il ya eu beaucoup
de périodes de crise dans cette dans
cette région et il ya d'ailleurs eu
treize mille morts finalement au cours
de ces conflits
le cessez le feu de du mois de juillet
dernier est assez mal respecté puisqu'il
ya encore quelques morts des deux côtés
de la ligne de cessez-le-feu en ukraine
et aujourd'hui on a en effet à une
situation extrêmement sérieuse avec un
regain de tension certains voudraient
décrire la situation actuelle comme le
remake du scénario de l'ossétie du sud
ans en 2018 en 2008 par dont ceux ci n'a
évidemment rien à voir
la situation est complètement différente
puisque aujourd'hui en réalité l'ukraine
n'a pas du tout l'intention de résoudre
le problème du dombass par des moyens
militaires son gouvernement l'a toujours
répété ce problème doit être résolu par
des moyens politiques
alors évidemment on peut toujours dire
que monsieur hélène ce qu'ils cherchent
à prendre son avantage d'autant plus
qu'il ya deux nouvelles administrations
américaines depuis le 20 janvier et
qu'il cherche à vérifier
de ce côté s'il est possible de gagner
une aide militaire supplémentaire ou sur
le plan politique de se rapprocher de
l'otan mais encore une fois la situation
est complètement différente de celle que
l'on a connue pour la géorgie en 2008
notamment parce que si il y avait un
problème important comme l'a dit dimitri
kozak
hier je crois c'est le responsable des
affaires russes régnait au kremlin eh
bien monsieur kozak a dit bien sûr s'il
est l'avis des russophones du dombass
dont certains ont des passeports russes
d'ailleurs été menacé la russie
interviendrait mais ça n'est pas le cas
parce qu'ils ne sont pas menacés et s'il
l'était et bien évidemment dans la
circonstances actuelles il est probable
que une intervention russe susciterait
cette fois ci une intervention
américaine ne serait ce que parce que
tout le monde regarde les américains y
compris les chinois le cred en tout et
appelle les les occidentaux a accéléré
son adhésion à l'otan pour envoyer un
message clair à la russie
comment est perçue cette réunion côté
russe karine béchec aux locaux justement
cette réunion remet largement en cause
le discours qui est effectivement est
menée mais c'est un discours selon
lequel l'ukraine veut une résolution
politique et non militaire du confit
tout d'abord il faudrait savoir ce que
l'ukraine est capable de vouloir et dans
quelle mesure à la les moyens de ce
qu'elle veut pour l'instant on peut
quand même sérieusement douter de
l'autonomie et de l'indépendance de
l'ukraine a décidé tant de sa politique
intérieure que de sa politique
extérieure puisque comme nous le voyons
chacun réforme intérieure est dictée par
des organes internationaux et ce qui
conditionne l'octroi d'un certain nombre
de prêts donc disons que la volonté
étatique de l'ukraine laisse quand même
beaucoup pas désiré en ce qui concerne
l'entrée dans l'otan c'est un à un pas
qui souligne une volonté de
confrontation puisque l'otan n'est quand
même pas une oeuvre caritative
c'est une organisation militaire et
c'est une organisation qui est déjà
extrêmement présente sur le sol
ukrainien
c'est une organisation qui a développe
les capacités de l'armée ukrainienne
donc on peut tout à fait considérer qu
effectivement tout état doit d'avoir son
armée claude marche pas on vous partager
également cette analyse en tout cas
cette intégration de l otan ça serait la
ligne rouge évidemment pour moscou on
imagine oui bien sûr mais je pense que
monsieur et 20 ce qui encore une fois
joue sa partition mais que pas plus que
la géorgie l'ukraine ne rentrera dans
l'otan dans un avenir proche
d'abord parce que dans le passé deux
pays européens la france est là et
l'allemagne s'y sont opposés en faisant
valoir que c'était un peu assez des
troupes agressif vis-à-vis de la russie
et ensuite parce que ce pays est un pays
divisé et que je ne vois pas bien un
pays divisé devenir un pays membre de
l'otan
par conséquent bien sûr il ya une
coopération comme le divin le professeur
cette coopération est importante mais je
ne vois pas dans un avenir proche
l'ukraine rejoindre rejoindre l'otan est
en réalité ce qui se passe c'est que
chacun essaie de tester le degré de
détermination de nouvelles
administrations byden après tout
monsieur byden avait été qualifié par
monsieur choï de sleepy jo et il montre
qu'il n'est pas
et puis jo qui n'est pas clean jo il
prend des décisions et effectivement il
est un peu obligé de les faire respecter
donc là chacun se regarde en chiens de
faïence je ne pense pas que la férule
chrétienne dégénère en conflit merci en
tout cas à tous les deux clubs
blanchemaison merci également à karine
besse i call back au colloque au pardon
arrêtez avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour ce décryptage et ce contexte
de tensions entre la russie et l'ukraine
est alimenté par des fêtes news venant
directement des états unis la chaîne cnn
dénonce via un reportage publié sur son
site les préparatifs de guerre de la
russie en montrant des images de chars
d'ukrainiens
les explications de david khalifa la
désinformation à son paroxysme quand la
définition même de l'objectivité fait
défaut à l'un des plus grands médias
américains
c'est comme ça que l'on pourrait résumer
en deux phrases elle ce reportage publié
par la cnn mais laissons parler les
images des images provenant des
téléphones portables ont émergé montrant
des colonnes armées et du matériel
militaire transportés par train vers la
frontière
sauf que ces fameux char ne proviennent
en aucun cas de la russie en réalité ces
images ont été tournées en ukraine et ce
matériel militaire et ukrainiens
la porte parole du ministère russe des
affaires étrangères maria zakharova n'a
pas tardé à faire aux journalistes
américains
une leçon de déontologie cher chaîne cnn
et son personnel amical
nous comprenons que vous n'avez pas le
temps de faire de la vérification des
faits vous qui êtes si profondément
ancrée dans la lutte idéologique au nom
du triomphe du libéralisme mais
présentait des chars ukrainien dans une
gare ukrainienne avec des wagons
ukrainien en arrière plan comme étant la
préparation à la guerre par la russie
c'est un peu trop la chaîne
d'information américaine a modifié dans
la foulée la photo de couverture de
l'article mais pour beaucoup
d'observateurs cet épisode est tout
simplement indécent surtout dans ce
contexte très tendu la sienne n'a pour
l'instant pas répondu à maria zakharova
m et aux états unis on pointe du doigt
un manque de professionnalisme et c'est
avec et les diagnostics c'est pathétique
c'est une faute professionnelle
journalistique c'est quelque chose qui
ne se fait pas une faute
il n'y a aucune excuse tube qui est dit
au fond les deux parties les corrompus
si c'était le monde réel il devrait
normalement être horrifié
et amis les seize the day by day subi
des têtes devraient rouler mais vous
savez ce qui va se passer à rien tout le
monde s'en fout vous savez pourquoi et
c'est très intéressant parce que c'est
cnn
c'est leur aptitude c'est leur excuse
leur camelot je suppose leur immunité
oui car la sienne elle n'en est pas à
son coup d'essai concernant la russie
accusant notamment moscou d'interférence
dans les élections américaines
souvenez-vous nous sommes en 2016
wikileaks dévoile une série d'e-mails de
campagne d'hillary clinton ou nous
découvre par exemple la manière de
gagner le vote des afro américains
l'équipe de campagne accusent le
gouvernement russe d'être responsables
de ces fuites et wikileaks d'aidé donald
trump la cnn peu de temps après affirme
avoir la preuve de ses accusations avec
un mail envoyé par un certain monsieur
ericsson prouvant l'existence de liens
entre donald trump et wikileaks
avant même la publication de ces emails
piratés mais la chronologie de la chaîne
est en fait erronée correction cet
article a été corrigée pour indiquer que
la date de l'e-mail était le 14
septembre 2016 et non le 4 septembre
le titre a également été changée et le
tweet de donald trump junior qui a
publié un message sur wikileaks le 4
septembre 2016 supprimer un défaut de
dates qui provoque un véritable tollé
puisque ce mail est envoyé en réalité le
lendemain de la publication de wikileaks
donald trump n'a pas cessé par la suite
d'accuser la chaîne de cette news
la sienne a tellement été responsable de
fausses informations concernant la
russie que le vice président de la
chaîne a demandé depuis 2010 est à
d'être dorénavant consulter pour toute
histoire liée à la russie et apparemment
ce n'a pas été le cas pour ces charges
soit disant russe le sommet de l'otan
avec au menu également le retrait des
troupes américaines en afghanistan il
est retardé de quatre mois joe biden
souhaite opérer
ici le 11 septembre date du 20e
anniversaire des attentats
une annonce qui a provoqué la colère des
talibans et l'inquiétude sur la scène
internationale concernant la paix dans
la région et précision de cyrielle
benavides bubulle ans l'heure est venue
de mettre fin à la plus longue guerre de
l'amérique
ce sont les mots de joe byden ce
mercredi le président américain s'est
exprimé sur le retrait de ses troupes
sur le sol afghan d'ici au 11 septembre
après vingt ans de guerre le président
américain souhaite rapatrier ses hommes
et mettre un terme à la présence
militaire en afghanistan
il a remplacé la date butoir
initialement fixé par son prédécesseur
donald trump et les talibans au 1er mai
afin de laisser quatre mois
supplémentaires aux forces américaines
et ainsi opérer un retrait ordonné un
non respect de l'accord fixé en février
2020 qui ne convient pas aux talibans si
l'accord est violée et les forces
étrangères ne quitte pas notre pays à la
date prévue
il y aura sûrement des problèmes et ceux
qui ne respectent pas l'accord seront
tenus pour responsables malgré cet
accord entre américains et talibans
signé en février 2020 à doha au qatar la
violence demeure à un niveau très élevé
sur le terrain entre insurgés et forces
afghanes
des négociations qui devaient être
relancé par la conférence sur la paix en
afghanistan
organisée sous l'égide de l'onu à
istanbul du 24 avril au 4 mai prochain
mais ce mardi les talibans prévenu qu'il
refuserait d'y participer tant que les
troupes américaines n'auront pas quitté
le territoire afghan
quant à la russie elle a estimé ce
mercredi qu'en revenant sur l'accord
washington risque
provoquer une escalade de violence en
asie centrale cela soulève l'inquiétude
d'une possible escalade du conflit armé
en afghanistan qui à son tour pourrait
saper les efforts du lancement des
négociations inter afghane dans ce
contexte nous répétons notre souhait de
préserver un dialogue constructif entre
les parties s'affrontent en afghanistan
et pour mener à la fin de ce long
conflit
si les états unis ne comptent plus que
2500 soldats sur place la mission résolu
tso porte de l'otan implique au total
neuf 1600 militaires à la date
anniversaire du 11 septembre
les troupes des pays de l'alliance
atlantique quitteront elle aussi la
castré pour en parler nous sommes avec
gérard vespière analyste géopolitique
chercheur associé à la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient bon choix
fait rare vesper merci d'être avec nous
alors tout d'abord pourquoi ce
changement soudain de la part de joe
biden c'est pas un changement soudain je
pense qu'il était effectivement d'un
point de vue matériel très difficile à
de bouger autant d'effectifs militaires
sur quelques jours ou en tout cas sur
quelques petites semaines
premièrement à deuxièmement il était
aussi difficile de faire en sorte que le
non respect par les talibans d'un
certain nombre je le dirai de
dispositions en particulier à le fait
qu'il est elle toujours mené des
attaques alors qu'il devait réduire à
leur activité à troisièmement que il
était il est absolument nécessaire pour
le futur qu'il y ait des contacts entre
le gouvernement a officiellement et les
talibans donc il a besoin de temps donc
il ya besoin de temps pour ces
pourparlers
il y a besoin de temps pour que les
troupes américaines et les troupes de
l'otan
on quitte le pays donc voila et le délai
supplémentaire à rentrer dans ce cadre
là alors on entendait anthony blinken
nous dire tout simplement que la mission
des états unis avaient
et accomplir réussi et donc qu'elle est
terminée tout simplement le président
afghan gagner assure lui que les forces
afghanes sont désormais pleinement
capable de défendre de l'afghanistan est
ce que oui
les etats unis ont réussi leur mission
et deuxièmement est ce que les forces
afghanes peuvent défendre l'afghanistan
toute autonomie
alors il est toujours difficile de faire
des parallèles aussi rapide n'est ce pas
mais si nous fermons les yeux et nous
revoyons la situation afghane en 2001
avec les talibans au pouvoir après la
l'élimination du commandant massoud
après la destruction des bouddhas de
bamiyan had qui avait plusieurs
plus de mille ans je pense que oui il y
a quand même une organisation de la
société afghane avec un gouvernement
avec une évolution des mentalités on
voit maintenant un certain nombre de
femmes de jeunes filles au travail on
voit des jeunes filles dans les écoles
qui est une évolution au cours de cette
génération une vingtaine d'années et est
ça je pense que ça va marquer les
esprits et la société afghane
il y a toujours l'afghanistan des
campagnes l'afghanistan rural
mais l'afghanistan des villes si je puis
dire et bien a quand même connu une
évolution est aussi une évolution
favorable de son pouvoir d'achat de son
niveau de vie
alors les taliban tout en sang sont pas
très contents de ce changement de la
part de joe biden retard la russie
estime un on a entendu de son côté que
ce retard risque de provoquer une
escalade washington revenons sur son
accord passé avec les talibans c'est un
risque réel que vous partagez une
escalade dans la région je pense qu'il y
à un autre paramètre qu'il faut aussi
citer c'est la présence de l'état
islamique n'est ce pas autant les
talibans les discussions ont lieu avec
eux autant les discussions ont lieu
aussi bien à moscou qu'à istanbul ou à
ankara
mais le problème qui peut à être nouveau
à pour l'afghanistan
c'est la présence de l'état islamique
qui se franchissent ce qui se prend à
mener un certain nombre d'attentats
contres en particulier la minorité
chiite musulmane afghanes donc le savent
être dans les années dans les mois à
venir
un sushi pour le pouvoir et aussi pour
les talibans d'être peu hors peut-être
déportés à sur leurs extrémités sur leur
radicalisme par un autre mouvement
djihadiste les américains ont promis de
continuer de soutenir le gouvernement
afghan à distance en ce moment
décidément liste en ciel en quoi ça va a
consisté je crois que le soutien est
d'abord et économique à l'illiade donc
depuis de nombreuses années des
démissions et a donc des organismes qui
ont apporté à des moyens conséquents
dont la distribution n'est fait
peut-être toujours été parfait
n'est ce pas la corruption existe dans
tout l'orient amer en tout cas c'est
l'âme de dans une situation apaisée en
afghanistan c'est d'un point de vue
politique à des négociations entre les
différents groupes et factions du pays
est aussi un développement économique
il y à un certain nombre de potentiels
dans le domaine du minerai il y a une
richesse du sol afghan pas forcément que
pour le podium il ya des possibilités
agricole donc voilà il faut que cela
puisse se mettre en place et les etats
unis eux auront un rôle à jouer
important qu'ils ont déjà mis en place
depuis vingt ans merci gérard vespière
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la situation
sanitaire gabriela talent promet
hommage aux victimes du coc vide alors
que le triste cap symbolique des cent
mille morts va bientôt être franchies et
mène maintenant présidera demain une
réunion pour aborder la sorte et crise
avec un éventuel calendrier à la clé sur
le front des vaccins l'europe accélère
avec thé vert bio tech les laboratoires
vont augmenter de 50 millions de doses
et livraison au deuxième trimestre
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris est vrai que le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec une jambe on mange un autre combat
on ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière s'agit d'un projet de loi qui
vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour
tous tes pieds coups politiques n'a
jamais été obligé de dire la vérité d
idée courageuse des mots qui comptent en
soi vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on est une gauche extrême
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
oh
20h30 heure française soit idée
bienvenue en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez conseil de défense
sanitaire ce matin dans un contexte
tendu alors que le cap des cent mille
morts du virus est sur le point d'être
franchie en france et qui vit sous la
menace des variants pour plus de
précision le riz mises à mal par les
retards ou déconvenue sur les vaccins et
qui vit sous la menace des variants pour
plus de précisions nous retrouvons tout
de suite en direct ben shemie en direct
de l'hôpital européen georges pompidou à
paris
bonsoir bessem des mesures de freinage
sont mis en place depuis maintenant le
20 mars sur tout le territoire
où en sommes nous effectivement
stéphanie plus de deux semaines après
ces fameuses mesures de freinage mise en
place par le gouvernement pour sortir de
cette troisième vague du coronavirus en
france la situation stagne toujours
alors qu'on atteint bientôt le chiffre
fatidique des 100 mille morts et
qu'emmanuel macron a fait à ce matin son
conseil de défense sanitaire son énième
conseil de défense sanitaire afin de
trouver la stratégie la plus appropriée
pour sortir rapidement de cette
situation bien sûr certains éléments
sont venus perturber la stratégie du
gouvernement notamment cette question et
ce problème du vaillant brésilien jean
castex a annoncé que des mesures plus
strictes à être mise en place avec ce
pays notamment au niveau est des
déplacements et puis bien sûr il ya eu
le lancement très controversé et
contrariant du vaccin johnson and
johnson le gouvernement doit donc faire
face à ces nouveaux contretemps pour
pouvoir sortir de cette crise cette
sortie de crise qui est prévu comme
emmanuel macron l'avait annoncé à partir
de mi-mai gabriel atta le porte parole
du gouvernement de son côté annoncé
qu'un hommage national sera rendu à
toutes les victimes du corona virus
jeudi à partir de 18 heures le chef de
l'état réunira certains membres du
gouvernement afin de réexaminer ce
processus de sortie de crise et de
réouverture notamment des bars des
restaurants et des lieux culturels
une échéance qui malgré tout reste en
danger au vu du nombre de patients
toujours en réanimation on en compte
plus de 6000 est la question que tout le
monde se pose évidemment la vaccination
va-t-elle pouvoir enfin accéléré
effectivement stéphanie le gouvernement
table vraiment sur cette campagne
vaccinale afin de sortir de cette
situation il a annoncé que les vaccins
et cette vaccination allait s'accélérer
semaine après semaine le porte parole du
gouvernement gabrel attal a assuré que
plus de 200 mille doses de vaccin
johnson & johnson seront disponibles et
bien sûr administré aux patients de plus
de 55 ans entendait les plus brefs
délais concernant le vaccin astrazeneca
qui fait parler de lui dont certains
pays européens l'ont interdit
définitivement comme le danemark le
gouvernement français lui a annoncé
qu'il avait confiance en ce vaccin une
confiance et une déclaration qui a été
appuyée bien sûr par la haute autorité
de santé concernant le vaccin biotech et
puis files heures l'union européenne
annoncé qu'il y aura une livraison et
plus de 50 millions de doses sur
l'ensemble du territoire européen et
bien sûr pour la france je vous propose
d'écouter concernant ces vaccins le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent nous avons reçu la première
livraison de vaccins johnsen c'est à
dire 200 milles 12 qui sont arrivés en
début de semaine sur notre territoire et
qui sont en train d'être acheminée
auprès de la médecine de ville et des
officines de pharmacie je crois que il
aura été entièrement acheminés
jeudi ou vendredi ce vaccin a bénéficié
des autorisations de la part des agences
de santé européennes et françaises et
donc à ce stade ce vaccin va évidemment
être distribuée est administré dans les
mêmes conditions que ce qui est prévu
aujourd'hui pour le vaccin
astrazeneca c'est à dire pour les
personnes âgées de plus de 55 ans alors
vous l'aurez compris cette stratégie
vaccinale reste larmes première est
préférable du gouvernement afin de
sortir de cette crise sanitaire et de
cette troisième vague et de corona
dirige aujourd'hui on compte un patient
sur cinq qui a reçu cette dose de vaccin
7 % des patients eux ont reçu les deux
doses de vaccin depuis le lancement de
cette campagne vaccinale le gouvernement
table sur plus de 20 millions de
vaccinés d'ici à au 15 mai ce qui pourra
à permettre au gouvernement de suivre sa
ligne de conduite est de sortir
progressivement de cette crise avec bien
sûr l'annoncé d'une réouverture à partir
de mi-mai annoncée par le gouvernement
et par emmanuel macron et comme je
voulais rappeler cette sortie de crise
reste bien sûr à discuter au vu de la
situation stagnante et de cette campagne
de vaccination qui a pris du retard sur
l'ensemble du territoire
mercy bay samedi en direct de l'hôpital
européen georges pompidou à paris
on l'a entendu dont report de weixin
johnson and johnson aux roms en europe
or élections la commission européenne
accélère le calendrier des livraisons de
13h biotech et entame de nous
négociations avec les fabricants pour
près de 2 milliards de doses
supplémentaires des doses de plus en
plus cher alors que de son côté le
spoutnik wehmeyer marché n'est toujours
pas autorisé par les autorités
européennes
guyomard aussi la stratégie vaccinale
européenne semble avoir du plomb dans l
aile après astrazeneca cette auto du
vaccin en scène des accusés des retards
de livraison
le laboratoire johnson & johnson a
annoncé ce mardi un report de son
déploiement en europe après le
signalement de caillots sanguins aux
états unis l'europe qui comptait
pourtant pour le deuxième trimestre 2000
21 sur 55 des 400 millions de doses
commandées à la firme américaine un
allongement du délai que l'on imagine
difficilement étrangers à l'accélération
des livraisons du vaccin fader annoncé
ce mercredi par la commission européenne
donc l'histoire je suis heureuse
d'annoncer que nous avons conclu un
accord avec pfizer bio ntmk krayzel
toujours accélérer une fois de plus la
livraison des vaccins et aux facs hince
fef 50 millions de doses supplémentaires
de vaccins pfizer biotech seront livrés
au cours du deuxième trimestre à partir
d'avril n'est pas élu e ne se contente
pas d'avancer le calendrier des
approvisionnements bruxelles a également
annoncé le début des négociations pour
l'achat d'un vaccin seconde génération
avec pfizer dont les produits à arn
messagers sont jugées plus efficaces et
plus adaptable face aux variants qui se
répandent à travers la planète
nous entrons maintenant en négociation
avec pfizer biotech pour un troisième
contrat contract des tracts pour ce
contrat prévoit la livraison de 1,8
milliard de doses supplémentaires de
vaccins au cours des années 2000 22 et
twenty two one twenty twenty free 1,8
milliard de doses soit trois fois plus
que toutes les commandes passées
jusqu'ici auprès du duo
germano-américain ou encore la moitié
des doses commandées en europe depuis le
début de la crise tous vaccins confondus
sauf que la facture pourrait bien être
plus salée que prévu 4 euros de plus par
dose
selon une déclaration du premier
ministre bulgare il ya quelques jours le
prix de pfizer était de 12 euros puis
augmenté à 15 euros 50
désormais pour 2022 et 2023 les contrats
de l'union européenne sont en cours de
signature pour 900 millions de vaccins
mais déjà au prix de 19 euros 50 19
euros 50 soit une hausse de plus de 25%
du prix négociés lors des deux premiers
contrats et qui ferait du sérum de
pfizer bio n tech le plus onéreux du
marché des vaccins anti qu'ovide à titre
de comparaison l'autre vaccin à arn
messagers celui de modern à a été
négocié par bruxelles à hauteur de 18
dollars la dose soit environ 15 euros
le vaccin de johnson & johnson est lui
encore deux fois moins cher environ 7
euros et une dose d'astrazeneca ne coûte
que quelques euros à bruxelles
sauf qu'outre les retards de livraison
ces deux derniers produits souffrent
d'une méfiance grandissante à leur égard
du fait d'effets secondaires rares mais
sévères
le danemark notamment à définitivement
renoncer ce mercredi au vaccin
astrazeneca et d'autres pays comme la
france ont circonscrit voir suspendu son
utilisation et spots nick v dans tout
cela
de nombreuses voix s'élèvent en europe
pour exiger de la commission européenne
qu'elle passe un contrat avec moscou
afin d'accélérer la campagne de
vaccination certains comme le land
allemand de bavière ont passé leurs
propres commandes du sérum déjà avalisé
par 59 pays
d'autant que le fonds souverain russe a
promis aux clients étrangers une dose à
moins de huit euros soit moins d'un
tiers du prix d'une dose de pfizer et on
a appris aujourd'hui que le président de
la région paca renaud muselier avaient
précommandé 500 mille doses de spoutnik
v mehdi toutefois attendre les
autorisations de laurent l'agencé
européenne du médicament prévue fin juin
pour les utiliser pour en parler
nous sommes avec jacques myard mer et
l'air de maisons laffitte bonsoir
jacques myard merci d'être avec nous la
précommande de renaud muselier de
spoutnik v elle est justifiée selon vous
il a il a raison de ne pas attendre en
tout cas il va attendre avant de
l'utiliser mais de d'anticiper des
choses
renaud muselier écoutez c'est assez
simple parce que toutes vos épisodes et
tout ce que vous venez dire ça s'appelle
la recherche du temps perdu et on
pourrait envoyer cet ouvrage de proust
au président de la république et aussi à
la commission de bruxelles
donc c'est trop chien du temps perdu sa
irrattrapable renaud muselier que je
connais bien qui est médecin a
parfaitement raison de commander des
doses de spoutnik tout en devant
attendre la mise l'autorisation de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
puisqu'ils ne pourrait pas le faire
sinon est en cours s'il y avait quelques
problèmes des condamnations et des
procédures judiciaires
mais en réalité il faut regarder les
choses telles qu'elles sont il est exact
que app line is you il eût fallu
négocier massivement celle qu'a fait
israël d'ailleurs ils ont payé et que
l'europe a voulu avoir le moindre prix
ce qui est une faute
dans une affaire comme cela c'est pas
une question de prix c'est une question
d'urgence
deuxièmement ce qui va arriver c'est
pour ça que il faut dire ado constituer
un français attention ce qui va arriver
ce sont des doses importantes surtout de
seconde vaccination
donc parce que il y a des délais celles
et ceux qui ont été vaccinés
il y a au mois de mars vont être
vaccinés
maintenant en avril et donc dans ces
conditions il ne faut pas s'attendre à
ce qu'il y ait à nouveau des premières
vaccinations et que les gens vont piaf
et surtout que le gouvernement a décidé
et là je crois juste titre qu'il ne
s'agisse
pas de passer par catégorie socio
professionnelle à savoir par exemple les
chauffeurs de taxi les professeurs mais
continuer sur le même je dirais un
différentiel d'âge
il ya eu des 75 ans les 70 ans
maintenant les plus de 55 et donc on a
encore devant nous je dirais beaucoup de
temps à voir et nous devons aider
français vont devront prendre leur mal
en patience
voilà la réalité parce que au début il
ya eu un ratage jacques myard justement
sur cette question du vexin rue st la
france insoumise le rassemblement
national
les républicains dont vous faites partie
la majorité commence à devenir très
isolé sur cette question puisqu'on voit
elle freine des quatre fers évidemment
nous a déjà prévenu qu on n'aurait pas
besoin de ce vaccin on voit bien que
c'est un souci pour eux de de l'accepter
comment expliquer sur l'art selon vous
alors écoutez il faut quand même
reconnaître que dès le début la france a
envoyé une mission à moscou pour vous
regardez ce qu'il en était et ça c'est
bien le land cède vous le savez a
déclaré dans une étude que c'était l'un
des meilleurs vaccins et qu'il
protégeait ensuite il ya un problème de
fabrication
et là je dirais nos amis russes doit
prendre en compte le fait que pour
livrer en europe
une fois que healy à l'autorisation de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
il y à la fabrication hélas il semble
quand même que la fabrication de ce
vaccin ne permettent pas de livrer tous
les états mais jacques bien sûr
donnez-moi mêler les rues seront rançon
près tout simplement ils l'ont dit hein
ils ne disent pas qu'ils sont capables
de fournir à inonder toute l'europe des
de leurs vaccins mais il se propose
justement de le fabriquer en
collaboration et c'est ce que soient les
allemands et les italiens pourquoi pas
les français alors que cap est d'accord
et je trouve que c'est une excellente
solution mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que pour fabriquer sa en commun et
préparer des usines où on va oui va ya
voir l'arrivée de la méthode du vaccin
sa fabrication ça se fait pas en quinze
jours pour regarder les choses telles
qu'elles sont vous savez il faut quand
même savoir que aujourd'hui l'humanité
avec un avantage réussi à mettre au
point des vaccins en un temps record par
rapport à ce qu'ils étaient je dirais
les méthodes antérieures donc il est
clair que c'est une très bonne nouvelle
que les russes proposent que le
gouvernement russe propose que l'on
puisse fabriquer en europe des vaccins
spoutnik
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il faut que
les usines qui vont devoir le faire
puissent s'adapter et ça ne se fait pas
en claquant des doigts
donc je pense qu'on est sur la bonne
voie je me félicite de l'offre multiple
de vaccins même si certains donnent font
peur à nos concitoyens à s'entraîner
qu'a
parce que ça c'est un problème réel même
si 30 millions de britanniques ont été
vaccinés avec astra zeneca il est clair
que les vaccins arrivent et que la mise
en oeuvre
c'est toujours la même chose pour nous
un peu de temps pardonnez moi mais ça
pose un réel problème on est en train de
jeter des doses que veut la défense le
danemark a annoncé qu'il arrêtait
astrazeneca l'europe d'ailleurs ne
reconduira pas le contrat l'année
prochaine l'a déjà annoncé mais nous on
continue tout de même idem pour johnson
and johnson pour l'instant il ya une
pause aux états unis après des
thromboses ça donne un sentiment qui
n'est pas très encourageant aux nombreux
c'est plus de france est un
tout de même j'avais il est évident que
vous avez toute une série de nos
concitoyens mais je reconnais autour de
moi qui vont refuser la salle seneca
tout simplement parce que ils se disent
certes les cas de thrombose sont rares
ça tombe sur moi ce sera trop tard donc
dit il est évident que ça pose ce
problème là ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est quand même la
multiplication des possibilités si je
mets à part
astrazeneca sur l'arrivée de nouveaux
vaccins y compris de scouts nique
donc je suis assez confiante mais on
n'est pas sorti du tunnel
il faut le savoir et c'est une mise en
oeuvre
vous savez il faut bien comprendre une
chose c'est que on a oublié que ce
vaccin ce virus allait durer mais vous
savez on a oublié que la grippe
espagnole en 1919
elle a duré plus de deux ans et donc
maintenant les dans la deuxième année on
va en sortir plus vite que dans la ville
espagnole
parce que nous avons des vaccins mais il
faut encore c'est la mise en oeuvre en
bas qui va durer et ça c'est
malheureusement quelque chose qui
s'impose un peu à nous tous en espérant
que les variants nous rattrape pas trop
vite
les calendriers déconfinement commencent
à tomber en notamment celui d' emmanuel
macron il ya une réunion demain en ce
sens un emmanuel macron qui avait évoqué
la mi mai pour commencer a clairement
réouvrir la france alors qu'on va
bientôt franchir la barre malheureuse
des plus de cent mille morts dans notre
pays vous pensez que ce calendrier de
réouverture et nabeul alors il côté
c'est un des points sur lequel je dis
que le gouvernement prend des risques
parce qu'à force d'assaut vous savez de
parler de la sortie du tunnel
et puis malheureusement ne pas pouvoir
tenir le délai c'est extrêmement grave
savait ce qu'on raconte une blague en
russie qui est mignonne vous savez c'est
un jour helsinki disait camarades on va
sortir au je vois le bout du tunnel
et il ya quelqu'un qui répond dans la
salle non camarade c'est le point qui
vient d'en face a et donc ce qui est
clair c'est que il faut pas annoncer des
choses comme ça il lui fallut d'ailleurs
ce que je reproche au président mac on
sait qui parle trop trop longtemps il
faut s'en tenir à des messages
bref il faut pas créer d espoir qui
risque de ne pas
tenue est-ce que ça va lui retomber
dessus et il est clair qu'on va en
sortir mais il faut être très prudent
sur la date de sortie
merci beaucoup jacques meyer maire a
l'air de maisons laffitte d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france
bonsoir est toujours dans notre pays le
plan hercules un projet du gouvernement
qui vise à réorganiser edf
il doit couvrir une partie du capital de
l'entreprise à des capitaux privés pour
la première fois il y a quelques jours
l'exécutif a envoyé un document aux
syndicats destinée à donner des
garanties sur le plan social les
explications thomas boni après plusieurs
mois plongé dans l'inconnu les
représentants syndicaux d'edf ont enfin
reçu des détails écrit de la part du
gouvernement concernant le fameux plan
hercules visant à réorganiser
l'entreprise
un document de trois pages publié par
nos confrères de mediapart dans lequel
bercy expose ses choix partant du
postulat qu edf n'est plus en mesure de
financer son développement
le gouvernement souhaite donc
réorganiser l'entreprise en trois pôles
deux entités 100% public qui détiendrait
80% de la production d'électricité en
france avec notamment une filiale dédiée
barrage mais le point de discorde
concerne la troisième entité dans le
document elle est présentée comme suit
une filiale contrôlée très
majoritairement par edf et qui sera
consacré principalement au développement
des activités renouvelables et aux
réseaux de distribution
le gouvernement affirme aussi que des
garanties légales seraient donnés sur le
maintien de cette filiale dans le
secteur public pour le reste le document
entretient le flou seule certitude le
nom hercules initialement donné au
projet est abandonné les salariés auront
le luxe de lui trouver un autre nom
malgré les promesses du pdg d'edf
estimant qu'il n'y aura ni scission ni
privatisation
l'entrée de fonds privés au capital
d'une partie de l'entreprise provoque la
réticence d'un large front syndical
mobilisés depuis des mois des salariés
de l'entreprise font part de leurs
craintes
voici quelques-uns de leurs arguments
recueilli ces dernières semaines et
demain cette transformation cette
ouverture de capital fera que
mécaniquement une grosse partie de
l'argent reçu
le résultat des entreprises partiront
dans les mains du prime et donc il
faudra les compenser notamment le
compenser des investissements etc à tous
les besoins par des augmentations de
tarifs ça c'est une évidence pour tout
le monde mais recule c'est prendre de
l'argent qui est produit par une
entreprise qui appartient à tous pour
donner les bénéfices qui sont dégagées
où les liquidités qui sont dégagées
uniquement à quelques-uns des projets
recul c'est le démantèlement d'edf le
démantèlement du service public
tout simplement donc demain c'est quoi
c'est une hausse des prix une précarité
énergétique encore plus importante
et cette notion de service public qui
pourrait ne plus exister
le document envoyé par bercy ne semble
pas destiné à calmer les ardeurs des
syndicats puisque aucune concession
concrète ni apparaît de plus beaucoup
s'inquiètent en réalité du débat en
cours avec la commission européenne car
c'est depuis bruxelles que se joue le
sort de df la réorganisation lancé par
le gouvernement est dans les faits un
moyen de se conformer aux règles de
concurrence imposée par l'union
européenne qui régule les tarifs et qui
oblige edf à vendre à ses concurrents à
prix fixe une part de l'électricité
produite par ses centrales nucléaires
et si les syndicats souhaitent aussi
s'extirper des obligations de bruxelles
ils ne soutiennent pas pour autant la
méthode employée par le gouvernement
l'entrée d'investisseurs privés dans le
secteur de la vente d'électricité
pourrait avoir des conséquences sur
l'emploi sur la souveraineté énergétique
et au final pour les consommateurs les
syndicats peuvent compter sur le soutien
de certains partis politiques de gauche
qui ont fait part de leur volonté de
lancer un référendum d'initiative
partagée sur cette question mais face au
rythme soutenu que semble vouloir
imposer le gouvernement les opposants au
projet font face à une tâche difficile
que l'on pourrait assimiler aux douze
travaux d'hercule
on le ségur de la santé à présent
l'assemblée nationale a définitivement
adopté aujourd'hui une série de mesures
destiné à réformer le secteur de la
santé est le rendre plus attractif
plusieurs de ces mesures étaient
promises dans le cadre de ce ségur
responsabilités accrues pour les
sages-femmes élargissement des
prérogatives pour les meilleurs qui
n'est autre profession paramédicale qui
font notamment partie des dispositions
approuvées
exit en revanche une proposition qui
prévoyait la création d'une profession
médicale intermédiaire entre les
médecins des infirmières et certaines
professions paramédicales et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec didier
béring
secrétaire fédéral de fo santé bonsoir
diby ring merci d'être avec nous quelle
est votre réaction ce soir après
l'adoption par le parlement de plusieurs
mesures ont eu une réaction qui est en
2005 parce que les mesures que nous
attendons aujourd'hui pour l'hôpital sur
de différends d'ordre ce soir le
parlement vient d'entériner des
recommandations qui était au départ
attendu par le ségur ce ne sont
certainement pas les plus importantes
que nous attendons aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital il y a eu les mesures
annoncées par monsieur bertrand hier ou
avant-hier plus exactement qui elles ont
été plus d'ordre salarial pour pour les
soignants qui qui était attendu depuis
de nombreuses semaines et nous attendons
toujours encore un geste très fort du
gouvernement sur sur les lits et sur les
effectifs
ça veut dire qu'en gros les mesures les
plus réclamés ce sont celles qui n'ont
pas été forcément retenu par le
gouvernement
très certainement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'hôpital a plus besoin
d'avoir une réflexion une politique que
très incisive par rapport à
l'augmentation du nombre de lits par
rapport aux par rapport à faire un
travail sur les effectifs possible pour
augmenter les effectifs aujourd'hui
venir parler de la gouvernance des
établissements
je pense que c'est prématuré parce qu'il
faudra que nous fassions un bilan après
la pandémie pour voir ce qui a marché ce
qui n'a pas marché et revoir peut-être
le paradigme d'en parler le président
macron il y a
il y a quelques mois lorsqu'il était à
mulhouse parce que ce paradigme
aujourd'hui il faudra très certainement
le changer parce qu'on me la crise de la
coved aura mis en exergue les grands
carence de l'hôpital de l'enfance
important ça fait un an malheureusement
le tragique épisode de mulhouse ça fait
maintenant un mois un an pendant un an
avant le début de cette pandémie
et pourtant pas grand chose ne semble
avoir changé comment vous
expliqué aujourd'hui c'est un manque de
volonté de la part du gouvernement
non je ne pense pas que c'est une
question de volonté du gouvernement je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut que l'on au
travail sur le modèle de l'hôpital voilà
sauf que c'est pas le moment parce que
les hospitaliers aujourd'hui sont
occupés dans la crise
ils ont la main aujourd'hui dans le soin
ils ont la tête
il était occupé à soigner la population
française qui arrivent de manière très
massive à l'hôpital et donc
et voilà ils ne sont pas en ce moment
dans une phase de réflexion par rapport
à l'organisation des soins et nous nous
avons besoin aussi aujourd'hui de
retrouver un petit peu de sérénité à
l'hôpital pour pouvoir bilan t
l'ensemble de cette séquence est donc
tiré les bonnes mesures
une dernière question justement quelle
est la situation concrète aujourd'hui
dans vos hôpitaux en moselle alors on
nous l aujourd'hui la situation est très
disparate par rapport à la moselle-est
la moselle on assure sur le secteur de
metz mais nous avons nos établissements
qui sont aussi en plan blanc nous allons
nous établissements où les personnels
sont extrêmement acide fatigué parce
qu'ils ont été sollicités de manière
très importante depuis maintenant 18
mois et donc la situation est vraiment
très très compliqué pour pour bon nombre
d'établissements de de l'autre
département
mais je crois que ce n'est pas qu'en
moselle que c'est comme ça je crois que
sur la région parisienne sept c'est
pareil
et il ya les hauts de france tu
également il ya toute la région de
marseille de nice qui sont aussi en flux
tendu on boit très bien qu'aujourd'hui
la situation est vraiment préoccupante
sur l'ensemble de de tout le territoire
et il faut bien sûr ajouter là dessus
les dom où on sait que la situation est
si préoccupante que ça soit on réalise
de la réunion ou bien ou bien aussi un
tout petit peu en partie merci didier
bering d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france resté avec mon dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
états unis qui souhaitent finaliser un
projet de
d'armes aux émirats arabes unis pour un
montant de 23 milliards de dollars et
puis nous ferons un point sur la
situation épidémique en france près de
cent mille personnes sont décédées du
cobp id un hommage devrait être rendu a
annoncé la porte parole du gouvernement
[Musique]
la sphère art chagos comment ce family
office at il réussi à provoquer un
nouveau vent de panique sur les marchés
mais aussi des pertes massives pour
plusieurs l établissement bancaire
utilisé l'effet de levier pour gagner de
l'argent en bourse ça se fait tous les
jours
en fait c'est toute cette incitation à
toujours pouvoir gagner plus avec
l'argent gratuit de la fed qui a
finalement poussé nombre de banques et à
suivre monsieur rang c'est quelque chose
qui nous a emmenés dans une catastrophe
en 2007 et en 2008
tous les tous les crédits ficelé goldman
sachs les morgan stanley était
évidemment pas au courant les uns des
autres quartiers gosses avaient autant
d'engagements à droite à gauche et c'est
en principe de l'opacité de la chose
peut l'annoncer dès maintenant vous
aurez des archers gosses en x 10
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une rose
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station mir ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
21h heure française soyez les bienvenus
en direct sur rt france pour cette
deuxième émission tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
14 avril aux etats-unis washington
souhaite finaliser un projet de vente
d'armes aux émirats arabes unis un
projet de 23 milliards de dollars de
ventes dont des avions de chasse f-35
des drones et d'autres équipements
joe biden avait mis en suspens des
accords établis avec les émirats par
l'administrateur de son prédécesseur
républicain donald trump afin de les
examiner
le coc vide gabriela talent promet un
hommage aux victimes alors que le triste
cap symbolique des cent mille morts en
france va bientôt être franchie quant
aux mesures pour les voyages avec les
pays le plus touché
elles devraient être durcies et présenté
lundi mnl mettront présidera demain une
réunion pour aborder la sortie de crise
alors que la réouverture du pays promise
à la mi mai interroge la justice fait
peau neuve pour restaurer la confiance
est l'objectif affiché par eric dupond
moretti avec sa réforme présentée ce
matin audience film et encadrement des
enquêtes préliminaires généralisation
des cours criminelles
le projet de loi sera examiné par les
députés en première lecture à partir du
17 mai un texte critiqué par les
magistrats et les avocats
[Musique]
des états unis vendons bien vendre des
armes aux émirats arabes unis la
transaction sera finalisée par
l'administration biden
le nouveau président américain avait
d'abord suspendu les écrans cet avis par
son prédécesseur donald trump afin d
examiner
finalement cette vente d'avions de
chasse de drones et autres équipements
aura bien lieu avec les émirats elle est
critiquée par certains élus américains
et par la communauté internationale en
raison notamment de l'implication des
émirats dans le conflit au yémen
et puis ce rapport qui incriminent la
police du capitole toujours aux états
unis pour sa gestion de l'assaut du
bâtiment par les militants pro trump le
6 janvier dernier
l' enquête de l'inspecteur de la police
révèle que les équipes de sécurité du
bâtiment aurait été au courant de la
préparation d'une attaque visant à
empêcher la confirmation de la victoire
de joe biden sur donald trump et
n'aurait pas réagi en conséquence les
détails avec hélène masquelier l'assaut
du capitole le 6 janvier dernier aurait
pu être évité c'est en tout cas ce que
suggère ce nouveau rapport de 104 pages
relayé ce mardi par les médias
américains
les conclusions de l'enquêté menée par
l'inspecteur général interne de la
police du capitole sont sans appel les
forces de sécurité du bâtiment aurait
été informé de la menace d'une violente
attaque contre le congrès à la
différence de précédentes manifestations
post électorales la cible des
manifestants pro tron pour le si ce ne
sont pas les contre manifestants mais
bien le congrès lui-même leur propension
à attirer des suprémacistes blancs des
milices et d'autres personnes prenant
activement la violence pourrait conduire
à une situation particulièrement
dangereuse pour le maintien de l'ordre
et le grand public en général
toujours selon le rapport la police du
capitole aurait été mis en garde dès le
21 décembre des commentaires sur un site
web pro trump sont signalés dans ces
échanges la promotion d'une attaque
contre des membres du congrès
ou encore la diffusion d'une carte du
système de tunnels des lieux
à porter des armes c'est maintenant ou
jamais nous ne pouvons pas leur donner
le choix
un nombre écrasant de soldats armés est
notre seule chance la veille de cet
épisode insurrectionnel le fbi haïr les
y est une autre menace provenant d'un
compte anonyme sur les réseaux sociaux
avec une rhétorique très claire ne
laissant aucune place au doute
soyez prêts à vous battre le congrès a
besoin d'entendre le verre se brise et
les portes enfoncées et le son des
soldats esclaves black live matters et
pendentifs à se répondre
soyez violent arrêté d'appeler cela une
marche un rassemblement ou une
manifestation
allez-y prêts pour la guerre nous
obtenons notre président ou nous
mourrons rien d'autre pour atteindre cet
objectif
malgré ces avertissements la veille des
faits la police du capitole recevait son
plan de gestion indiqué dans le document
en noir sur blanc
l'absence de menace spécifique connu lié
à la cession extraordinaire des deux
chambres prévues ce jour là la police
reçoit également l'ordre de ne pas
employer de méthodes trop offensive à
savoir l' usage de grenades
assourdissantes
s'ajoutant à cette liste de manquement
l'emploi d'équipements non fonctionnels
et vétuste autant de dysfonctionnements
qui interroge sur la sécurité du congrès
outre atlantique
suite à cet assaut qui a fait quatre
morts et 140 policiers blessés les trois
hauts responsables de la sécurité ont
démissionné et se rejettent depuis la
responsabilité des faits impossible pour
le moment de savoir exactement ce qui
s'est passé ce jour là
en attendant ce nouveau rapport ne passe
pas inaperçu il fera d'ailleurs l'objet
d'une audition ce jeudi au congrès
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houston avec dave perkins
animateur radio analyse politique
supporters de donald trump c'est notre
rubrique lui de l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors si
on en lit ce rapport sur cette attaque
contre le capitole du 6 janvier
finalement on nous dise ça aurait pu
être évitée est ce que c'est votre trois
avis également
je ne le pense pas je pense que l'ordre
à la police de ne pas pas intervenir de
ne pas déployer leurs arbres plus
puissantes sont venues des niveaux les
plus élevés du parti démocrate je pense
que nancy pelosi a ordonné à la police
du capitole de se tenir en retrait car
elle voulait utiliser cet événement ou
dans le cadre de son programme en titre
up antirépublicain et on a bien vu
maintenant qu'ils ont dressé des
barricades déployer de manière
permanente la garde nationale nancy
pelosi affiche son inquiétude face à
donald trump et à ces manifestants
qualifié de terrorisme domestique
il est évident d'après les vidéos que
les policiers se sont mis en retrait ont
même introduit les manifestants dans le
bâtiment ont ouvert les portes et ce ne
sont pas les images d'un département de
police se défendant contre l'invasion de
terroristes on dirais plutôt qu'il
s'agissait d'une mise en scène qui
seraient utilisés plus tard comme outil
de propagande alors le procès a montré
également que cet événement était tout
de même planifié mais il semblerait que
certains manifestants voulaient juste
participer
une dernière manifestation pro trump de
manière pacifique mais d'autres disaient
au contraire vouloir empêcher la
certification du scrutin et punir les
traîtres inde du congrès ça s'est
retourné contre ses premiers
manifestants dit pacifique mais il faut
le nombre de mes amis étaient présents
j'ai reçu des détails très précis de ce
qui est arrivé devant le capitole
j'en suis certain des personnes dans
cette foule à avaient été introduits
afin de la rendre plus violente que si
les choses s'étaient développées tout
seul il y avait des membres dans tifa
dans cette foule
il essayait de pousser à la violence de
pousser à l'insurrection
le manifestant ne sautait pas pénétrer
dans le capital ne souhaitait pas punir
les le comté il voulait faire rien de
violent qui puisse être sur le dos des
pacifistes
je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de
partisans pro trump qui ont fait des
bêtises et les actes est le plus grave
la violence la plus forte a qu'une
brutale que l'on voit sur les images il
semble bien que cela soit le fait de
personnes qui n'étaient pas des
partisans de donald trump
les partisans de 20 à 30 le savent et
moi aussi car je me suis rendu à de
nombreux rallyes j'en ai passé je ne
pense pas que les partisans de 30
étaient les responsables des plus gros
acte d perkins on va revenir sur cette
information dont on parlait il est tout
juste quelques minutes un le
gouvernement byden qui avait suspendu la
vente d'armes aux émirats arabes unis
conclu en novembre par donald trump et
bien finalement elle wable poursuivre ce
contrat on attendait d
changement de joe biden quelle est votre
réaction
il ya beaucoup de choses que donald
trump a initié et que joe biden et son
administration continue qu'il s'agit de
la politique vaccinale de politique
étrangère comme les ventes d'armes avec
les émirats arabes unis joe biden est
bien content que donald trump et réussi
à pousser une normalisation des
relations avec israël ce qui permet
cette vente d'armes mais il faut se
rappeler que l'argent ne revient pas aux
états unis mais revient au fabricant de
ces armes les personnes qui ont
construit ce et ses avions ses drones
ces projectiles
cet argent les entreprises s'attendait à
la recevoir arrêts et des donateurs
républicains et démocrates voulaient
donc cette langue se fasse et ne
souhaitait pas que de raiden l'empêcha
et joe biden n'a pas trouvé de bonnes
raisons pour empêcher cette vente est
effectivement pour moi il n'y a pas de
bonnes raison d'empêcher cette vente car
les emirats-arabes-unis doit pouvoir se
protéger à l'avenir contre des années
comme l'iran au niveau régional alors
vous le savez aussi les émirats arabes
unis qu'ils soient impliqués dans le
conflit ou du maine qui tue beaucoup de
civils
par conséquent beaucoup critiquant ses
ventes d'armes
aux émirats arabes unis vous ne pensez
pas qu'il aurait fallu que joe biden la
coupe puisque lui justement éprouvent
souvent aux leçons morales liesse ville
mont royal et du bic aux doubistes un
certain côté je les pense effectivement
et serait logique jo dan à 10 je suis
meilleur que donald trump
nous sommes une administration plus
morale que la dissension trump
nous devons empêcher cette vente pour le
bien des civils au yémen mais aux états
unis la plupart des gens ne savent pas
qu'ils sont le combattant dans le
conflit du yémen ne savent pas que vous
menez si on souffre parce que les médias
américains ne prennent jamais le temps
d'expliquer la situation que yémen
correctement donc c'est un angle mort
pour la nuit pour le public américain et
je pense que l'administration bailon
comprend mettre en danger les civils
yéménites dans le renforçant l'armement
désignera car le public ne comprend pas
et ne leur reprochera pas toujours au
niveau international joe biden qui a
annoncé le retrait avec quatre mois de
retard par rapport au calendrier de son
prédécesseur de retrait des troupes en
afghanistan
finalement on se rend compte et vous
l'avez d'ailleurs un petit peu dit qu'il
ya assez peu de changements il n'y a pas
une grosse rupture entre les deux
administrations en tout cas en ce qui
concerne la politique étrangère la
compétence nécessaire pour faire son
travail
les gens qui font le travail pour lui
les gens qui me disent qui prend ses
décisions
sachez que donald trump était un
dirigeant raisonnable à mesure et qui
avait de bonnes raisons pour ses actions
et qu'elle est à l'encontre des
décisions de donald trump
parce que c'était les siennes est en
général une mauvaise stratégie
ils doivent trouver une façon
d'expliquer à leurs électeurs pourquoi
ils font la même chose que de la trempe
là il s'agit là que de l'humour il faut
présenter la situation de manière
lénifiantes l'eau c'est une spécialité
des démocrates ils sont très bon
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'axé les gens de
l'échantillon et après avoir tant lutté
contre donald trump effectivement et les
problématiques qu'ils continuent dans
cette voie
merci beaucoup d'être perkins d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur air france
ce soir merci à vous et on disait donc à
joe biden qui a annoncé le retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan d'ici
auront septembre 2021 soit vingt ans
jour pour jour après les attaques du
world trade center alors où les
militaires américains sont ils encore
présents dans le monde
la réponse en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
aux etats unis toujours après avoir
montré des images de chars ukrainien
censée montrer des préparatifs de guerre
russes la chaîne américaine cnn est une
nouvelle fois dans la tourmente
filmé en caméra cachée l'un de ses
directeurs techniques a confessé que la
chaîne d'information aurait tout fait
pour évincer donald trump florian
lambert
la chaîne américaine cnn at elle
participé activement à la défaite de
donald trump
c'est en tout cas ce qu un directeur
technique du média a concédé en caméra
cachée charlie chester un cadre de la
chaîne a été la victime de plusieurs
faux rendez vous amoureux filmés à son
insu
chester confie à son interlocutrice que
cnn aurait tout fait pour évincer donald
trump
je vais le dire et je le pense à 100%
sans cnn je ne sais pas si trump
pourrait été viré à un moment donné la
main de trump tremblay ou quelque chose
comme ça nous avons fait appel à
plusieurs médecins pour raconter une
histoire selon laquelle et c'était de la
spéculation
il avait un soucis neurologiques c'était
de la propagande une propagande anti
trump savamment orchestrée en croire
charli questeurs et qui aurait donc
profité un certain joe boyd nous
montrions toujours des photos de baden
faisant du jogging et en bonne santé
vous voyez avec ses lunettes d'aviateur
ou le montrions comme une jeune personne
âgée je pense que c'est grâce à nous
qu'il a été élu
des déclarations assez lourde de sens et
pourtant charlie chester nom n'est pas
sa dernière confession
selon lui la prochaine campagne d'
influence de la part de cnn serait déjà
déterminé
notre objectif était de mettre trump à
la porte sans le dire notre prochain
objectif concernera la sensibilisation
aux changements climatiques
ces révélations concernant le vote de
novembre risque de faire parler ces
prochains jours
et d'appuyer la thèse d'une franche des
républicains et du clan trump selon
lesquelles l'élection lors a été volé
quant à cnn elle n'avait pas forcément
besoin d'une telle publicité
après les images de chars ukrainien
illustrant une invasion russe supposer
le parti islamiste hizb ut tahrir se
revendique comme une organisation
pacifique s'il est défendu par des
défenseurs des droits de l'homme ce
parti est aussi interdit dans certains
pays musulmans en compte son idéologie
et radicale les précisions de notre
correspondant à moscou on verra goffman
revendiquant une présence dans quelque
70 pays
le mouvement international hizb ut
tahrir à des projets un bichon en
khalifa qui s'étendrait à travers le
monde du pôle nord au pôle sud en monde
où la charia ferait office de loi
un monde où les infidèles père est une
taxe pour vivre et comme l'indiquent des
brochures joliment imprimer tout cela
sera mis en place de façon pacifique
apparemment juste après avoir tué les
juifs
l'entité juive est en concert et un
cancer est quelque chose dont il faut se
débarrasser
il boude tahrir ne cesse d'insister
malgré tout sur le fait qu'il s'agit
d'un gourou pacifique et certains
notamment les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme les croit sur parole
j'attends de mes collègues croient les
organisations sur parole si une
organisation affirme qu'elle est en
faveur de la paix de l'amitié et qu'elle
n'incite à rien de néfaste il faut la
croire sur parole et la protéger
si dans leur livre il est écrit qu'ils
sont pacifistes cela veut dire qu'ils
sont pacifistes la secte aum shinrikyo
que je viens de mentionner avait
l'idéologie la plus douce
il était interdit de tondre le gazon
pour ne pas blesser les faits qui habite
dans l'herbe les plantes d'intérieur
était aussi interdite pour ne pas
compliquer la vie des parasites qui
vivent sur les fleurs mais cela ne les a
pas empêchés de tuer 50 personnes et de
planifier d'en tuer 4 millions
supplémentaires
il se boude tahrir est interdit en
allemagne en russie et dans la plupart
des pays musulmans mais ils passent sous
les radars de nombreux pays occidentaux
hizb ut tahrir à l'islam y constitue une
grande menace c'est une organisation
nettement structurés dont le but ultime
est de renverser les gouvernements
laïque en prenant le pouvoir par la
force afin d'instaurer par la suite le
règne de la charia ses membres sont
entraînés dans des zones de guerre sous
les pavillons d'autres groupes
ils sont particulièrement actifs en
crimée où ce groupe terroriste n'a été
interdit qu'en 2014
alors imaginez la confusion provoquée
par la décision de kimonos rights watch
de soutenir les membres de his book
tahrir en les qualifiant je cite de
militants politiques
la semaine dernière un tribunal
militaire russe a condamné cette attaque
de crimée à des peines allant de 13 à 19
ans de prison
cette condamnation s'inscrit dans une
série de poursuites politiquement
motivés qui ont lieu en crimée occupé
par la russie depuis six ans nous avons
deux mandats human rights watch
d'expliquer en quoi l'arrestation de
membres de his book tahrir constitué des
poursuites politiquement motivée mais
notre question restée sans réponse c'est
effectivement difficile à expliquer
comment peut-on les défendre l'un de
leurs arguments et que his book tard il
n'est pas interdit en ukraine
par conséquent ce serait intéressant de
voir comment ki-moon rights watch
justifiera les appels d'un des
dirigeants de cette organisation en
ukraine à exterminer les juifs et à
brûler les lgbt qu il n'y a qu'une seule
solution pour israël avec la bénédiction
d'allah lorsque tous les musulmans
s'uniront nous mettrons fin à ce
problème
rien d'autre n'aidera ni les
déclarations communes ni les feuilles de
route vers la paix allah a envoyé de la
roche fondue sur les homosexuels
donc tout d'abord nous devons les brûler
et ensuite
jeter des pierres c'est le bon moyen de
les punir
mes collègues sont pas venus à
interviewer une ex membre de hizb ut
tahrir
ils recrutent surtout des jeunes
ils sont dénuées de pensée critique
ils sont crédules lorsque vous êtes un
nouvel arrivant sans parents n'y a ni à
proximité
il est très facile de tomber sous leur
emprise
il y a eu des cas with bout de tarir
fanatisés les jeunes ils disaient nous
devons faire quelque chose
les infidèles sont partout et cela
remplissait les jeunes de négativité les
incitant à voyager quelque part et à
faire quelque chose à ce sujet les etats
unis qui montre ice watch et d'autres
encore se sont mobilisés pour soutenir
les tatars de crimée arrêté pour
appartenance à isbu de tarifs comme ils
l'ont fait il ya quelques décennies
lorsque l'union soviétique le thé contre
les talibans ce n'est que lorsque les
tours jumelles de new york se sont
effondrées en 2001 qu'ils ont réalisé
que les talibans n'étaient peut-être pas
à l'héro qu'on nous avait présenté ou
les jadistes chaînes et les appeler
combattant de la liberté quand il
faisait exploser des immeubles et des
stations de métro en russie bien sûr les
acclamations ont cessé lorsque cette
même idéologie a débouché sur
l'explosion de deux bombes lors du
marathon de boston en 2013 on espère
juste que dans dix ans personne ne devra
appeler les urgences après un attentat à
l'explosif commis par isbu de tahrir
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du coc vide en france
alors que la barre des 100 me
on va bientôt être franchie gabriel at
elle annoncé qu'un hommage aux victimes
seraient rendus et puis nous évoquons la
réforme de la justice présenté ce matin
par eric dupond moretti
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début c'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
et eric bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il tourner les
impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés que c'est impossible
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour à bagdad alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernière
poche leur procès
en 2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui c'est tous les fromages tous
les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très estimé
enfin les français ne savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
en sibérie vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sens du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï tg légende
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose alors jean francky
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct yves ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle pour vous
c'est quoi finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle nous souhaitons parler
avant tout à toutes celles et ceux qui
n'y croient plus qu'ils s'abstiennent
aujourd'hui voyez il ya énormément de
français aujourd'hui qu'ils ne veulent
plus aller voter puisque vous parlez de
son nouveau souffle à gauche
cela s'inscrit dans l'ordre d'un
rassemblement on a du mal à comprendre
l'idée d'une candidature communiste je
ne souhaite pas que dès maintenant on
nous dise et bien vous n'avez pas le
droit de présenter votre candidature de
quel droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
ça laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français souhaitent
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
[Musique]
l'agité pour tous ce que ça apporte aux
enfants
c'est une confiance confiance en soi ils
ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des gros poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et à écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison bas ça va
être difficile
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt francs si
vous me rejoigne et conseil de défense
sanitaire ce matin dans un contexte
tendu alors que le cap des 100 morts du
virus est sur le point d'être franchie
en france un pays toujours en plein
troisième bad dont la stratégie est mise
à mal par les retards ont été convenues
sur les vaccins et qui vise toujours
sous la menace des variants les
précisions de baisse en chimie
alors que le cap des cent mille morts
sera bientôt en france atteint mordu
coronavirus emmanuel macron a organisé
ce mercredi son énième conseil de
défense sanitaire deux semaines après la
mise en place des différentes mesures de
freinage mais voilà un calendrier a
perturbé par de nouveaux éléments
notamment le variant brésilien jean
castex le premier ministre a annoncé que
des mesures plus strictes allait être
mise en place avec ce produit avec ce
pays et notamment en terme de
déplacement il ya eu aussi le lancement
contrarier du vaccin
johnson and johnson qui vient de
perturber un petit peu la campagne
vaccinale française le gouvernement doit
faire face notamment à ses nouveaux
contretemps pour préparer sa sortie de
crise prévue à partir de mi mai comme
l'avait annoncé emmanuel macron le chef
de l'état de son côté gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement a annoncé
qu'un hommage national sera rendu à
l'ensemble des victimes du coronavirus
jeudi à partir de 18 heures le président
de la république réunira certains
membres de son gouvernement pour
examiner ce processus de réouverture
notamment des restaurants des bars mais
aussi des lieux culturels
une échéance qui vient bien sûr être
mises en danger est perturbé par la
situation est chaotique et vit
actuellement la france notamment en
termes de réanimation plus de six mille
lits en réanimation sont actuellement
occupées en france le gouvernement table
bien sûr sur cette campagne de
vaccination pour sortir de cette
troisième vague de coronavirus une
troisième vague qui est loin d'être
derrière nous comme l'a annoncé
diabré natale le porte parole du
gouvernement qui est revenu sur cette
campagne vaccinale je vous propose
d'écouter le porte parole du
gouvernement
nous avons reçu la première livraison de
vaccins johnsen c'est à dire 200 mille
doses qui sont arrivés en début de
semaine sur notre territoire et qui sont
en train d'être acheminée auprès de la
médecine de ville et des officines de
pharmacie je crois que il aura été
entièrement acheminés
jeudi ou vendredi ce vaccin a bénéficié
des autorisations de la part des agences
de santé européennes et françaises et
donc à ce stade ce vaccin va évidemment
être distribuée est administré dans les
mêmes conditions que ce qui est prévu
aujourd'hui pour le vaccin
astrazeneca c'est à dire pour les
personnes âgées de plus de 55 ans diabré
natale qui a bien sûr annoncé que plus
de 200 mille doses du vaccin johnson and
johnson seront réceptionnés en france
est administré aux patients de plus de
55 ans concernant le vaccin astrazeneca
qui fait beaucoup parler de lui dont
certains pays de l'union européenne ont
interdit la diffusion et la distribution
notamment le danemark le gouvernement a
réitéré sa confiance auprès de ce vaccin
une confiance et une déclaration qui a
été appuyée notamment par la haute
autorité de santé concernant le vaccin
biotech et pfizer plus de 50 millions de
doses seront réceptionnées sur
l'ensemble du territoire européen
aujourd'hui on compte un patient sur
cinq qui a reçu déjà sa première dose et
7% qui ont reçu et déjà lors de doses le
gouvernement bien sûr table sur plus de
2 millions de vaccinés d'ici au 15 mai
et pour parler de la campagne vaccinale
nous sommes avec patrick box médecin
généraliste vous foire festive
merci d'être avec nous vous étiez l'un
des premiers à donner l'alerté en mars
2020 sur le kobe d'aujourd'hui vous
tiriez la sonnette d'alarmé sur le
manque de dos puisqu'on rappelle vous
êtes médecin à mulhouse mulhouse
des toutes premières vide très frappé
par la pandémie
oui mais nous a été frappé de plein
fouet en mars 2020 exactement ça a été
le départ d'épidémie actuellement le
constat qu'on peut faire c'est que les
médecins sont sous dotées de vaccins on
en a peut pas assez il ya une rupture de
stock on est les livraisons sont
différées et surtout nous n'avons pas
accès aux vaccins arn donc le modern and
their on n'y a pas accès c'est à dire
qu'on est vraiment limité dans la
capacité de vacciner les gens fragiles
que nous voyons en danger et pour les
mettre à l'abri avec la vaccination
là je vous ai tout de suite parce que je
ne comprends pas bien pourquoi votre
région n'a pas accès au vaccin est reine
alors je ne sais pas il ya eu 1
apparemment ce que j'ai entendu c'est
que la moselle on serait doté un peu de
modern art mais pour l'instant
l'ensemble des médecins juristes de
france ne sont pas dotés des vaccins
allen voulait venir uniquement chez les
médecins parce que ça effectivement le
sait puisqu'il ya des problèmes de de
conservation difficile avec notamment le
kaiser en revanche on dispose miens de
l'astra zeneca vous en tant que médecin
généraliste
oui on halak sera zeneca mais qui est à
ce jour très limité parce que ces
dernières semaines nous avons droit à un
flacons de dix doses
donc c'est très très peu et encore il ya
quinze jours nous n'avait pas été dotée
du tout quant au vaccin moderna j'ai
entendu ce que disait monsieur attal
effectivement nous avons pu commander un
flacon de cinq doses hier mais il sera
livré le 22 et 23 avril donc la semaine
prochaine et donc aux prêts à vacciner
seulement la semaine d'après parce que
les vaccins on n'organise pas comme ça
les vaccinations à vendredi après midi
ça s'organise à partir du lundi
ça veut dire qu'à partir du 26 27 avril
nous pourrons utiliser nos cinq doses de
vaccin johnson c'est mike sendall on va
pas très loin d'autant qu'on peut sans
l'astra zeneca on le sait c'est un petit
peu le voilà le vaccin maudit en ce
moment le danemark a annoncé aujourd'hui
sa suspension l'europe a d'ores et déjà
annoncé qu'elle ne commanderait plus
l'année prochaine
il y à il ya une vraie suspicion de
votre côté également chez vos patients
sur ce vaccin ou les mulhousiens se font
bien volontiers vacciner y compris avec
ce vaccin là ça devient honnêtement
difficile pour convaincre les gens alors
ce qu'on leur dit c'est très simple
c'est cap au delà de 50 ans en gros on
n'a pas vu d'effets secondaires de type
coagulation chez les gens donc on peut
les gens de plus de 50 ans 55 ans de
toute façon on peut utiliser le vaccin
en toute sécurité pour les jeunes bien
sûr on ne le fait pas d'autant plus que
les gens sont très réticents ils ne
veulent pas le faire
ils ne veulent pas le faire une très
grande réticence même si les gens qui
seraient éligibles les gens de plus de
55 ans qui seraient éligibles aux
vaccins commence à devenir très
dubitatif et il faut vraiment beaucoup
d'arguments pour les convaincre à se
faire vacciner dans nos cabinets sa de
angie ce entre les changements constants
de cible de stratégie de pénurie de
vaccins et maintenant le refus des
patients ça devient vraiment très dur
pour nous les généralistes de continuer
de vaccination on est vraiment très
désabusée ces derniers temps vous
craignez le même phénomène avec le
johnson & johnson
je rappelle que ce vaccin a été mis en
pause aux états unis après après le cas
de citron beauce dont d'ailleurs un mort
en france on a 200 mille doses mais pour
le moment on ne sait pas trop vous
craignez en fait les suites de ce vaccin
également c'était à mon avis tout à fait
prévisible il semblerait bien que ce
soit un effet lié au vaccin adénovirus
qui provoque ce genre de thrombose
arrêts sont extrêmement restreint pasqua
bien aux états unis il ya eu sur 6
millions de doses vaccinales distribuer
il ya eu je crois
trois ou quatre accidents extrêmement
peu on est bien d'accord c'est moins
grave que de prendre la pilule et hume
et en même temps qui est beaucoup plus
dangereux
mais les gens ne veulent pas le
comprendre il ne veulent pas accepter
qu'un vaccin qui est là pour les
protéger pourraient être toxiques
pourtant il va bien falloir qu'on fasse
quelque chose parce que la stratégie
vaccinale tech 1 basé ce vaccin est un
des nos villes russes pour vacciner dans
les mois qui viennent la population
jeune et active et donc ça va poser un
problème évident comment ça se passe
dr vendent au sein de l'ue vaccinodromes
de mulhouse est ce que les choses sont
un peu plus apaisé ça se passe mieux que
dans vos cabinets de généralistes
alors je crois que dehors je sais pas
trop ce qui s'y passe parce que j'y
travaille pas parce que je suis occupé
dans mon cabinet c'est un choix on a si
j'ai choisi de vacciner intensivement
cabinet même si on n'arrive plus j'ai
quand même réussi à faire près de 180
vaccins en un mois maintenant ça va
beaucoup plus lentement
je crois que dans les vaccinodromes ils
ont accès à thoisy mans tous les vaccins
le kaiser le modern à l'astral je crois
qu'ils en ont aussi donc je sais pas on
n'est pas sur le même pied d'égalité
très honnêtement malheureusement aurez
bientôt franchir les 100 mille morts en
france alors qu'on parle de
déconfinement emmanuel macron une ligne
en ce sens demain déconfinement mi mai
c'est ce qu'on nous avait promis un plus
ou moins le chef de l'état vous croyez
que c'est toujours possible
je suis un peu inquiet comme mieux comme
tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il faut le
on a très bien compris qu'il fallait
accélérer la vaccination il fallait que
toutes les vies pour ce vide sanitaire
soient assis sur la vaccination
on voit que les médecins légistes on a
un public côté et puis on voit qu'il ya
deux de 25 ans sont quand même important
pour cette façon là sera et le johnson
sont créés ralenti donc il va falloir qu
au déficit abyssal de vaccination
convaincre la population dit peut-être
essayer d'aller un peu plus vite
dernière question rapidement sur ces
variants le variant brésiliens notamment
qui fait si peur en tant que co médecin
vous l'appréhendez comment on nous dit
que c'est sa force en france aujourd'hui
alors il ya dans de grands s est pas mal
de variantes sachant variés anglais est
majoritaire et jeu pro dernières données
de la rs il y avait 500 de variants
tiens on voit pas beaucoup d'effet en
cours c'est sûr que il a été déconseillé
de vacciner avec ses astra en moselle et
donc il se développe le modern a
intensivement chez nous dans le grand
est à mulhouse on n'a pas encore vu
vraiment de résistance aux vaccins astra
mais on n'a pas
deux chiffres n'ont plus de retombées
quoi il a supplié évidemment merci
beaucoup patrick boc messin général huré
nullos d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france et restaurer la confiance
justement c'est l'objectif affiché du
garde des sceaux avec cette fois sacrée
forme de la justice audience film et
encadrement des enquêtes préliminaires
généralisation des cours criminelles
le projet de loi sera examiné par les
députés en première lecture à partir du
17 mai un texte critiqué par les
magistrats des avocats eric dupont
moretti a présenté ce matin en conseil
des ministres l'ancien donc avocat grand
défenseur de la présomption d'innocence
et coûte aujourd'hui quand on est
suspect on se retrouve dans le cadre
d'une enquête préliminaire qui est
éternel
ça s'appelait avant 59 l' enquête
officieuse
c'est toujours une enquête officieuse
vous ne savez pas à quelle sauce vous
allez être mangé vous ne savez pas quand
ça se termine
san est enserrée par aucun délai et moi
je dis que c'est gravement attentatoires
aux droits de l'homme
d'autant que vous n'avez jamais de
fenêtres contradictoires les procès
verbaux
ce n'est pas ce qu'il ya dedans et vous
n'aurez un accès à ce n'est que bien
plus tard dont vous ne pouvez pas vous
défendre et pire encore je le fais de
procès à personne mais c'est un constat
parfois vous les journalistes vous avez
les procès verbaux denquête préliminaire
alors que l'intéressé lui-même ne les a
pas c'est quand même un monde c'est
quand même un comble donc je lancèrent
dans des délais c'est enquête
préliminaire que j'ai beaucoup consulté
notamment des magistrats notamment des
policiers des avocats également jeu
lancèrent dans des délais et
deuxièmement jeu permet l'ouverture au
contradictoire et pour en parler nous
sommes avec marie
et perron vice président du conseil
national des barreaux ancien bâtonnier
paris bonsoir marie-aimée 0 mais avec
nous une première réaction à ce projet
on le rappelle censée restaurer la
confiance des français en justice
écoutez en tout cas s'il y avait
longtemps il y avait même 10 ans 1
depuis la présence de l'avocat lagarde
en garde à vue que notre ministère de la
justice ne se souciait pas du
justiciable
et ça c'est indispensable de savoir que
d'encadrer les enquêtes préliminaires
dans des délais c'est indispensable
l'injustice ne peut plus être aussi
lente et c'est un premier pas il y
aurait beaucoup de pain à faire pour
restaurer la confiance des français dans
leur justice puisque un français sur
deux n'a pas confiance en sa justice
mais ça c'est une mesure qui est
importante que on puisse encadrer dans
le temps une enquête préliminaire vous
ne pouvez pas être victime avoir déposé
plainte et d'avoir aucune nouvelle ou
être poursuivis et ne pas savoir en fait
poursuivies avoir une enquête qui vous
concerne ne pas être informé c'est à
dire d'être informés obligatoirement
dans l'année c'est indispensable
qu'est-ce que ça va changer concrètement
ça et va provoquer une vraie
accélération du rythme judiciaire très
lent en tout cas on ne peut plus
accepter que des enquêtes préliminaires
dur pendant des années et des années et
des années
les français ne comprennent pas cela et
sur ce point nous sommes je suis
personnellement tout à fait d'accord
avec cette mesure qui va permettre
d'accélérer les enquêtes le problème
néanmoins ce sont les moyens financiers
de la justice et les moyens humains à
dire que nous avons besoin de magistrats
nous avons besoin de greffiers nous
avons besoin de davantage de moyens pour
la justice en france
alors on sait qu eric dupond moretti est
un ancien avocat aujourd'hui a quand
même quelques avocats qui ont grincé des
dents à prenons l'exemple de la
généralisation des cours criminel
départemental
on rappelle la petite phrase quand même
un mois et demi avant son arrivée place
vendôme le garde des sceaux disait c'est
la mort de la cour
6 ceux qui préparent les projets de loi
à la chancellerie ce sont des magistrats
en déplacement donc c'est un projet fait
pareil pour les magistrats qu'est ce que
vous répondez nous nous répondons
naturellement que nous sommes en total
désaccord avec cette généralisation des
cours des cours criminel départemental
comment voulez-vous quand une loi de
confiance pour la justice fait pour le
justiciable
on supprime les jurys pas les jurys
populaires en tout cas pour les pour les
débits pour les pour l'epr ce que la
peine encourue est qu'entre 15 à 20 ans
c'est pour rétablir la confiance
c'est certainement pas en supprimant les
jurys populaires sur des crimes qui sont
des viols
le plus souvent ça concerne des viols ou
les victimes ou les parties ont besoin
de ce temps les plaids les personnes
poursuivies ont besoin de se tendre
d'injustice et nous avons une justice
qui fonctionne très bien qui sont les
jurys populaires
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec cette
généralisation
après une expérimentation qui n'en a pas
été une un puisque il ya eu très peu de
temps en fait pour expérimenter ces
chambres départementales cessant
criminel départemental est d'ailleurs le
rapport qui a été déposée à l'assemblée
n'est pas si convaincant que cela
pourquoi un tel revirement de la part du
garde des sceaux selon vous christian
saint-palais un président de
l'association des avocats pénalistes lui
porter un jugement sévère en eric dupond
moretti a choisi son intérêt personnel
dit-il
c'est ce genre de raison qui explique je
ne penserai peugeot je ne nierai pas en
ce sens aujourd'hui ce n'est pas eric
dupond moretti avocat
c'est eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux est vraiment sur ce point j'irai
que si le garde des sceaux se
contredisaient par rapport à ce qu'il
dit en tant que ministre cela me
gênerait qu'il se contredisent par
rapport à l'avocat ça nous concerne
personnellement mais en attendant nous
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec cette
suppression des assises pour ces
dossiers qui sont
des crimes est ce que ce sont là encore
une fois ça concerne plus
particulièrement les viols il a hélas
souvent nerveux souveraineté du peuple
un jeu rappelle que la justice est
rendue au nom du peuple et supprimer le
peuple dans une loi de confiance
pour la justice c'est une erreur à mon
sens tu ne il ya un élément aussi de
cette réforme les audiences film est
restitué est ce que c'est une avancée
pour vous oui bien sûr bien sûr mais à
condition d'encadrer bien évidemment
c'est à dire que ça va permettre au
français de davantage connaître leur
justice
mais il faut l'encadrer par rapport au
parti par rapport à la victime par
rapport à l'ensemble des parties
puisqu'il est question de faire
connaître aussi la justice civile c'est
vrai que les français n'ont pas ne
connaissent pas le fonctionnement de la
justice
éviter cet entre soi mais il convient de
veiller d'une part à bien à obtenir les
autorisations
elles sont prévues mais je n'ai pas vu
de demande d'autorisation aux avocats et
aux magistrats concernés et puis tout
simplement ne pas le droit à l'oubli
c'est à dire de veiller au droit à
l'oubli donc oui mais à condition d'en
cabrette bien évidemment le projet
bouygues prévoit aussi d'imposer un code
de déontologie pour tous les
professionnels les avocats notaires
greffiers des tribunaux de commerce
est ce que c'est un effet d'annoncé cela
va vraiment changer les choses et
qu'est-ce que ça va changer
alors pour les avocats savane ça ne
changera rien puisque toutes les façons
nous avons notre côte d or de
déontologie la discipline
vraiment ça ne modifiera en rien et je
rappelle que contrairement aux greffiers
contrairement aux huissiers au notaire
nous ne sommes pas des officiers
ministériels et que notre discipline et
notre déontologie par le conseil
national des barreaux
nous le nous l'assurons totalement nous
gérons plus de 6000 plainte à paris et
auxquelles nous répondons en permanence
là dessus je
nous sommes en discussion avec notre
ministre et je pense que le parlement va
avoir beaucoup à compléter ce projet de
loi bava voie d'avoir amélioré ce projet
de loi dans le cadre de ses travaux
parlementaires
merci marie aimée peyrens vice président
du conseil national des barreaux ancien
bâtonnier de paris merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france dans
le reste de l'actualité deux ans après
l'un sont ni de notre dame les
enquêteurs ont terminé leurs
investigations dans les décombres mais
il faudra encore attendre l'analyse de
prélèvements qui doit encore durer
plusieurs mois pour déterminer l'origine
de l'incendié
jusqu'à présent des zones d'ombré
subsistent plus d'explications avec mona
amont dès lors le 15 avril 2019 la
cathédrale notre dame de paris bat 6 850
ans plus tôt perdre et sa flèche sa
toiture son horloge une partie de sa
voûte la destruction partielle de ce
symbole de la france ravagé par les
flammes avaient suscité une vive émotion
dans le monde entier dès lors les
enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
avaient pour mission de retrouver des
indices dans les décombres compte tenu
de la fragilité de l'édifice
il avait même dû être formés par des
cordistes pour pouvoir effectuer des
prélèvements au dessus des voûtes et
puis tu arrives et l'épidémie de kobe de
19 qui a ralenti l'enquète qui n'a
finalement repris qu'en novembre dernier
mais deux ans après l' incendie peu
d'éléments filtre sur l'avancée de
l'enquêté néanmoins on sait qu'une
centaine de témoins ont été entendus
lors de l' enquête préliminaire lancée
par le parquet de paris alors accident
ou acte criminel
le rand février 2020 le procureur de
paris a donné un élément de réponse à ce
stade aujourd'hui nous restons sur
l'hypothèse qui a fait l'objet d'une
communication
l'hypothèse accidentelle nous n'excluons
jamais rien dans une enquête mais ce que
l'on peut dire c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'élément nouveau aujourd'hui qui
accréditerait une hypothèse criminelle
un an après cette déclaration rien ne
semble suggérer davantage la piste
criminelle les enquêteurs semblent
privilégier la piste d'un court circuit
ou celle d'un mégot l'essai et par les
ouvriers qui montait un échafaudage sur
la foule
du monument en parallèle plusieurs
défaillances dans la sécurité de la
cathédrale ont été identifiés notamment
en mauvais entretien des installations
électriques le dispositif d'alarmé de
l'édifice défectueux l'appel tardif aux
pompiers en raison d'une erreur
d'interprétation de la larme ou encore
un dysfonctionnement du système
électrique d'un des ascenseurs et des
failles qui ne seraient pas à l'origine
de l'incendié mais qui aurait laissé aux
flammes
le temps de se propager dans tout
l'édifice les analyses des prélèvements
sont attendues dans les mois à venir
elle pourrait apporter de nouveaux
éléments de réponse on se souvient de
l'élan internationale après le sinistre
près de 830 millions d'euros avaient été
récoltés des fonds qui avaient fait
polémique
l année dernière la cour des comptes
avait ainsi pointé du doigt
l'utilisation des dons par
l'établissement public chargé de la
restauration de notre dame et des dons
censé être exclusivement dépensés pour
les travaux de réparation et mais qui
aurait servi à payer les salaires du
personnel de la cathédrale ou encore le
loyer de l'établissement public pour la
restauration une utilisation des dons
est désapprouvée par la cour des comptes
le problème est qu'il y à une
débudgétisation c'est à dire que
normalement un établissement public de
ce type doit être financé sur des fonds
publics
or là c'est l'argent des donateurs qui
est utilisé et ses donateurs envisage
ces dons uniquement pour la restauration
de la cathédrale
non pas pour la valorisation d abord la
communication ou le fonctionnement de
cet établissement public
le chantier de la restauration a déjà
commencé il vous sera peut-être possible
de visiter à nouveau notre dame de paris
dès avril 2024 et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
point complet sur l'actualité
nous
[Musique]
la faire à mes gosses comment ce family
office at il réussi à provoquer un
nouveau vent de panique sur les marchés
mais aussi des pertes massives pour
plusieurs l établissement bancaire
utilisé l'effet de levier pour gagner de
l'argent en bourse ça se fait tous les
jours
en fait c'est toute cette incitation à
toujours pouvoir gagner plus avec
l'argent gratuit de la fed qui a
finalement poussé bon nombre de banques
à suivre monsieur c'est quelque chose
qui nous a emmenés dans une catastrophe
en 2007 et en 2008
tous les crédits ficelé goldman sachs et
morgan stanley était évidemment pas au
courant les uns des autres que arte jégo
savez autant d'engagements à droite à
gauche et c'est en principe de l'opacité
de la chose peut l'annoncer dès
maintenant vous aurez des archers gosses
en x 10